Barry Allen they call him the fastest
man alive he is not up is down black is
white do not get distracted by anything
you see along the way
so reverse-flash
but so much one fun to be bad it's
pretty messed up
yeah this is ground zero for pretty
messed up
hey youtubers it's Charlie so some extra
presents just got delivered the flash
dropped some new footage it's really
like the same trailer with some extra
scenes and there's really two big things
going on there's some mirror master
stuff happening and some earth-2 stuff
happening if you didn't miss that last
trailer video that I posted there's a
new round of the reverse flash ring
giveaway that's going on now - there's
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I've got new arrow footage new
legends of tomorrow footage so all
announced the winner whenever I post
those videos later but the biggest thing
to me in this trailer like the big
difference from the last teaser that
they dropped was that Jay Garrick is
like don't get distracted up is down
black is white I think he's talking
about the mirror universe but you see
like Grant Gustin walking into the earth
to police station the mural is even very
different - we have to talk about that
in a second but episode 10 like the next
episode whenever the flash comes back is
supposed to be the mirror master episode
you know just based on the IMDB
description so I think that we're gonna
see a version of the mirror universe and
then we'll also see that characters go
to earth - if not an episode of 10 then
in episode 11 or 12 police station
killer frost iris West all the all these
scenes in the trailer all earth-2 stuff
but because the laws of physics are the
same on earth - i don't think that jay
garrick's voice-over is talking about
earth - specifically so let's talk about
the mural real quick in the police
station because there's like this really
it was this really elaborate set piece
that they built for season one of the
flash it was super beautiful and it
depicts the Justice League using the
Greek gods but the earth - mural looks
just a little bit different it's like
the Justice Society version of that if
you never read the Golden Age or the
Silver Age comics just to explain earth
- just conceptually what happened is is
DC had all its Golden Age heroes like
Jay Garrick is the Golden Age flash
Barry Allen is the Silver Age flash so
when DC wanted to revamp all of its
characters in the Silver Age started you
know it brought it a new Barry Allen he
took over for Jay Garrick what it did is
is it took all the Golden Age characters
and said that they existed on earth - so
it was like all their adventures all
their lives everything that happened in
those comics in the Golden Age comics
was happening on earth - so that's how
DC chose to explain the earth 1 Justice
League existing along with just a
society and then being able to do
crossover issues where they both teamed
up but they don't show this entire earth
- mural so I'm curious to see what's up
at the top here but I can't wait to see
the characters from Earth
go to earth-2 that's what we haven't
seen yet every time we see an earth -
it's been a flashback it's been like a
Harrison wells flashback or a Jay
Garrick flashback there's like a whole
history of all these earth two
characters that I'm sure that they've
mapped out at least a little bit at
least the biggest characters like they
probably had a pretty good idea what
Harrison wells backstory was before the
season but you know as they build out
new comic book characters they have to
fill in their backstories you know even
if it's not something that we get to see
on TV and I think part of the reason why
we haven't gone to earth 2 yet is
because they want to set up this core
conflict with all the main characters on
earth one and then they don't want to
give away too much about what might be
going on with zoom because the more we
learn about earth - the more we learn
about the creation of zoom just to be
clear I know that I know there's still
tons of theories about who zoom could be
but remember the way the way they
pitched the accident the particle
accelerator explosion on earth - he was
created just like Barry Allen was
created so it's someone from their
present day just I think the Patti
speech at the beginning of the season is
really important she's basically telling
sand demon to go eat a dick like you got
powers because you were in the right
place at the right time so I think zoom
is all about the idea of like what
happens if somebody else got struck by
the lightning instead of Barry just
someone who happened to be in the right
place at the right time
and speaking of zoom I feel like him
holding her up here is the best evidence
the Patti is not zoomed so like just one
more theory to cross off the list but
let me know what are you most excited
about when the show comes back I mean
there's a lot of legends of tomorrow
stuff happening but just just for the
flash specifically personally I like I
cannot wait to see killer frost but I'm
probably to do next is I'll either do
like legends of tomorrow or my arrow
trailer next then I'll do my Doctor Who
Christmas special video and then like
whatever's left after that there's also
some other cool Captain America Civil
War stuff but I'll probably do that on
Sunday so while you guys wait for
everything to post you can click here to
watch the Deadpool red band trailer
again so awesome is such a great trailer
and you can click here for my latest
Star Wars Easter eggs video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight